good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-993
object class safe
special containment procedures any
broadcasts of scp-993 are to be
intercepted
as detailed in protocol upsilon beta 3
and blocked from public viewing all
intercepted broadcasts are to be
recorded
and stored for future viewing any
subjects used to view scp-993
must be under the age of 10 and are to
be dosed with a class a amnesiac
after they have described the episode
viewing of scp-993 must be authorized by
three
level four personnel description
scp-993 is a children's television
program entitled
bobble the clown which first began
airing in
19 scp-993 seems to have been made in
the style of an educational cartoon
with the primary plot of most episodes
being the titular character
bobble the clown learning a new skill or
activity
the program appears to have no
supporting cast and the setting of the
program
often changes between episodes scp-993's
anomalous properties become obvious when
the program is viewed
anyone watching aged 10 years or older
will immediately fall unconscious
when the program begins and will remain
incapacitated until the end of the
program
later reporting a stabbing headache
immediately before blacking out
children under the age of 10 viewing
scp-993
later report that it teaches and
advocates activities
such as cannibalism torture
these activities appear to become
ingrained in the subject's mind
repeated exposure to scp-993 can result
in permanent psychotic
and schizophrenic symptoms episodes of
scp-993 are regularly broadcast from a
currently unknown source
but since 2000 all broadcasts have been
successfully intercepted using protocol
upsilon beta 3
and blocked from public viewing episode
log
episode title bobble's kitchen surprise
setting of episode is a stereotypical
small american town
in the episode bobble the clown appears
to kidnap one of the town's citizens
and takes him to his home once there
bobbly clown informs the viewer on how
to prepare
human flesh for consumption then
proceeds to skin
gut and cook the citizen episode title
bobble in the big city setting of the
episode is a large american city
possibly new york in the episode bobble
the clown instructs viewers on methods
of lighting fires
undetected using resources such as
mosquito coils
at the end of the episode bomber the
clown sets fire to a large building
and leaves the picture stays on the
burning building for a further three
minutes
before the episode ends screams are
audible during this time
episode title bobble sneaky saturday
setting of the episode appears to be in
london as the elizabeth tower housing
big ben is visible
in the episode bobble the clown silently
stalks a woman for most of the episode
when she arrives at her home bobble the
clown attacks and kills her with a large
butcher's knife
at the end of the episode bomb of the
clown details methods of remaining
unseen
in crowded places episode title bobble
gets the truth
setting of the episode appears to be a
prisoner of warcamp
in the episode while the clown tortures
a captured soldier
repeatedly asking him nonsensical
questions the soldier eventually appears
to die of his wounds
bobble the clown then details to the
viewer how to inflict painful
but non-lethal injuries episode title
bobble hates you setting of the episode
appears to be a blank room
bobble the clown sits on a chair in the
room staring angrily at the viewer for
the full
30 minutes of the episode episode title
u u u setting of the episode appears to
be site
video archive where recordings of
scp-993 are stored
in the episode bommel the clown angrily
details methods of breaching containment
for several scps bobble then details
methods to murder researchers involved
in its containment
showing detailed knowledge of their
daily routines and habits
notably what appears to be an animated
version of doctor
walks past bobel halfway through the
episode a clock on the wall shows the
time is
pm doctor confirms that he was walking
past scp-993's archive
at the time the following is an audio
recording of a bobble the clown episode
entitled bobble's back playing log now
hello there no no don't get up
put the gun down though
it won't do anything i'm not real
how could you shoot me
there we go see isn't that much
nicer all friends
[Music]
face the window please oh and smile
there that's good
you look surprised doctor you've been on
a binge of me
haven't you i like your style
you fall down and then you just get back
up
[Music]
shave though that's what let me in
[Music]
nice couch don't get up i'll make myself
at home
what are you talking about doctor oh
no i'm gonna come here as some sort of
vengeful retribution i really don't mind
you people watching me
although i do wish you'd share them
you're very selfish taking me away from
the children like that
you know i admit i did lose my temper
for a bit back there didn't i
don't worry i've come to terms with my
new audience
you do let me at children quite often
some people will call you monsters
not me i don't judge
i'm fair
what are you writing i'm very sorry
doctor but this
isn't an interview i put it in the trash
there we go everything goes in the trash
eventually
you trash your precious interview the
children trashed their little
minds and even i had to trash some of my
other gimmicks
oh yes i've been making little savages
for
quite a while now doctor we put
down the gun i think it started off
small the idea of fire some stupid
cavemen got in their skulls
children didn't really have time for me
back then so
i moved on the skinwalker stick though
that that was a good idea
children whispered about me in the dark
adults even painted me they hardly had
to do anything at all
but then you had to get clever
didn't you suddenly all those
superstitions
started to float away and i had no
children
to help no parents to be
well you'll find out soon enough
and yet there was one little form that i
had left
one fun-loving character that i could
still reach inside those
kids heads and twist
i'm talking of course about bobble the
clown
don't look so glum smile
you're on television
[Laughter]
and log as of 2000
it appears that cp 993 has ceased
broadcasting
as of 20 scp-993 has resumed its normal
broadcasting
reclassification to euclid is being
considered
episode title bobbles back setting of
episode appears to be in dr
office bobble appears to be in the room
and doctor
registers shock then faces the viewer
and smiles
bobble and doctor then appear to
converse for 15 minutes
although no dialogue is audible 15
minutes in doctor
raises a pistol and fires upon bobble to
no effect
bobble then systematically dismembers
and removes facial extremities from dr
using a large butcher's knife signs of
movement are visible from doctor
for three minutes after which the
credits roll
alarmingly doctor disappeared without a
trace
a day before the episode broadcasted
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran the morrigan
retalias karim el ashmuy
big onion bean sayo dio demnatus
revenant brian sanchez
cesar hintern patrick bailly
matthew gilmore eric corbich
kawaii fire keeper longinus
carcass ethakwa king maring
james saba nj vojak
and oblong doucheboy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you